then the oscar-nominated film The Cider  House Rules  please welcome Tobey Maguire and Erykah  Badu  makeup artist today do far more than  create flawless complexions their part  illusionist and part technological  wizard assisting us in our escapes up on  the big screen here are the nominees for  best achievement in makeup for Austin  Powers The Spy Who shagged me Michelle  Burke and Mike Smithson for Bicentennial  man greg cannom  for life Rick Baker  for topsy turvy kristine Blundell and  tougher proud  and the Oscar goes to  Christine Blundell and trapper crowd for  topsy turvy  the first Oscar nomination  both the speed blundell and tougher  prowl  Wow  what can we say lightly top guy you are  so brilliant thanks to rest of our team  and thanks thank you